now escaping the regular gridlock on the
road by just flying over it sounds like
a plan to me and there are those that
believe that flying taxis will be a
thing soon among them are people at the
german company lilium
which has come up with a prototype it's
to carry six passengers and the pilot
with a range of more than 200 kilometers
take a look
this is atlas test center in spain
a very special aircraft is about to take
off
phoenix ii the prototype of the flying
taxis of the future that is developed
under high pressure by german company
lillium
the startup is in competition with
hundred other developers worldwide all
of which seek to be one step ahead in
the approval process
every flight is a new chapter
we say that test flying
is like testing the boundaries
next limit
and then the next and one also has to be
ready to take a step back
phoenix ii flies unmanned and is
remotely controlled
one pilot six passengers and a range of
more than 200 kilometers that's how
these flying taxis aim to compete with
cars and trains especially in urban
areas
i'm an engineer i understand the physics
behind this aircraft
when i stand next to it see it flying
and hear how quiet it is and the way the
whole team built it to operate safely
even for me it's like a miracle
another miracle lilium needs is to
achieve the ambitious goal of making
more than 5 billion euros worth of sales
in just a few years
daniel vegan has been heavily criticized
due to these kinds of promises but that
hasn't damned vegan's ambition
once our long-term vision is that we
want to make regional flights
sustainable
as well as making them accessible to as
many people as possible
the prototype has successfully completed
around 30 test flights in spain and its
software is still being adjusted in the
beginning only particularly valley
clients would be able to travel by this
kind of air taxi but we gone is not
alone independent traffic experts say
the sky is the limit for more electric
aircrafts